david where do you believe the ideology
of trumpism
comes from is it a discernible
historic ideology this is a really
really great question
there's been quite a bit written about
what exactly is the origin of this
ideology now
aside from the we'll get to the academic
literature if you ask me like how do i
describe the ideology of trumpism
it's really an anti-ideology it's an
ideology not based on policy
it's an ideology based on almost like a
perverted post-modernism
focused on just owning the libs
angering people on the left foe populism
that's really what it's been about and
there's a lot of academic work about
this that sort of aligns with what i'm
suggesting
um it's kind of like an amalgam
of conspiracies skepticism of government
unless it's your guy and a desire to
exact
revenge and impose punishment on those
who you see
as your political enemies some call it
postmodern conservatism
um post-modern conservatism is
almost like it some describe it as a
reaction
to what the right sees
as bad identity politics okay
post-modern conservatism where you talk
about alternative facts the truth can be
whatever we want it to be
the reality about what we are told what
is it what is it a lie and what is the
truth
it's all subject to who is the right
trying to embarrass or
insult or own and i think post-modern
conservatism
is a very interesting way to kind of
name the trumpian
ideology mark blythe calls it
global trumpism and matthew goodwin
has used the the phrase national
populism it's like a nationalistic
populism we've talked about
right-wing nationalism versus left-wing
nationalism i'm sorry
right-wing and left-wing populism where
the rhetoric is often very similar
and people start to think oh i'm a
bernie person but a lot of the rhetoric
sounds similar from trump maybe i'll go
with trump
and then you see the solutions are stop
people from s whole countries
and china this and china that and antifa
black lives matter they're going to take
your house they're going to take your
kids they're
you know all this different stuff so
that's another part of it
there's this kind of like my truth world
that is very important to trumpian
ideology
personal experience is what matters
anecdote is what matters
rather than empirical thinking and and
the scientific process
public discourse academia those things
don't matter
in this ideology uh i think that the
the other part of this that can be
tricky
is donald trump appealed to a lot of
people who were previously apolitical
and so when we look at the way
that trumpian ideology and again i get i
understand it's sort of an
anti-ideology but to the extent that
it's an ideology
all of these people stuck to it oh trade
yeah trump will fix trade and we're
being treated unfairly
these were not people really convinced
to switch to that from something else
a lot of these folks never had a
political ideology and trump brought it
down
to the lowest coarsest level we've
arguably ever seen politics which was
too
boring for a lot of these people all of
a sudden was kind of interesting
and it was never going to be about
policy or procedure or science or
empiricism
these were folks who never cared about
this stuff before
and they were in it essentially for the
memes and the slogans
uh and the mottos and that's all it was
ever
going to be for them and now the
question is do they stay involved in
politics or as politics gets quote
boring again do they just bail and that
is as important
the absence of an ideology is a huge
part
of the trumpian ideology and i think we
need to understand that and the question
is to whether those folks remain
involved with trump gone it's still a
question mark we've seen trump
lose some support through attrition from
the republican party over the last month
but he still has a lot of it
it's just going to be a question we have
to wait to really be able to answer in
full
send me your thoughts and let me know
how how would you characterize
trumpian ideology we've got a great
bonus show for you today as well
the show continues if you are a member
sign up at joinpakman.com and you can
use the code
secret code new code okay listen to this
youtube 50 youtube 50
new coupon code which you can use at
joinpakman.com
we'll see you on the bonus show i want
to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david